okay before anything else Michelle needs
to get Barney cleaned up but on their
way to the bath Barney won't walk
Michelle suspects
Barney rarely left his cage walking on a
leash and taking a bath could both be
frightening he's maybe never had a bath
or if he had maybe they hosed him down
in the cage
all right an examination of Barney's
footpads reveals what's been irritating
his paws
his feet are covered in feces we
realized that there was a lot of poops
tucked in between his pads which
probably was very uncomfortable my guess
is that you know he's been stepping in
his own poop and it's bothering him so
he's trying to clean himself and get rid
of the irritation and he's like sores on
to his feet
Barney's sores could never heal
his licking and living environment
constantly irritated he spent a lot of
time in a wire cage which might have
caused his feet to be really irritated
are you going
barney is frightened at first but
quickly calms down
once the feces in dirt are removed
Michele is shocked by the severity of
Barney's lesions I do feel bad for
Barney Barney's feet definitely seen
painful they're really irritated they're
raw you know I mean there's open sores
so clearly they hurt him
it's hard to say why Barney started
falling asleep ahead of his bath I'm
sure he felt so much better that he
could finally relax you're beautiful
before he was really oily and and he
smelled pretty bad but Barney's looking
beautiful now he's got a beautiful coat
too silky and his hairs all brushed out
and he you can see his eyes and and he
just seems lighter he's beautiful